you guys how's the honeymoon phase four
months yeah yeah it's great I love it I
just flashed the bling all the time I
love it me on that Thanks
her fingers look like that so oh no what
is it what is it my hands look like this
so hardest could look like this we are
very close to hearing of who is in the
new Dancing with the Stars cast I heard
today that there was one female spot
left and I have been campaigning hard
every night on Entertainment Tonight to
take that spot I have an excellent M yes
well I guess you have to be a celebrity
technically so it's like a little hard
but that was the unspun do you know
who's your part who your partners are we
don't even over on the show so no way
you know if you're on the show so we go
have no idea so you would know more than
I was would you like to be back on the
show of course great show watch the show
this fall premiering September 16 you
were on the show wink-wink nudge-nudge
these two kids who would your dream
partner be Dina hey Dina
casting I'm ready do you have a do you
have a dream like do you like I have an
athlete do you like to have an actor do
you like to have a way back when star I
I don't know
nostalgia star like can't really dance
but like everyone loves them because
they were I would love like a football
player I haven't had one yet so that
would be really fun I think you could
just like throw me across the dance
floor I would love that
for you for you Jack it's gonna be some
changes this season have you heard from
anyone like how they're changing up how
it works I tell you we have not heard a
thing I heard everything anything you
can tell me about this season of Dancing
with the Stars that is gonna be probably
the best season we've had thus far and
it's gonna be fresh and new and I'm
excited for the audience to see it I
think because it's been a minute there
was so many seasons back to pack I mean
you guys were just in a grinder go go go
go and we sat we took we took a beat and
now to bring it back there feels like
there's a fresh energy around the
patient and the excitement I think so
it's gonna be I think really big yeah
there's an anticipation and I think
people miss it our fans definitely miss
it and we miss it you know and I think
that something that's gonna make this
season very special you have spoken to
me at Great Lengths about how important
family is to you and you want to be a
daddy is this the time to start
practicing kids I mean I don't have to
have kids to be a daddy daddy we want
kids not right now yeah we won't enjoy
being married so
you
[Music]